- Who here is already pro basketball player?
- Mr. Dončić, they're only seven.
- You are behind! Children, I am ancient 23-year-old.
I've had it all figured out for decade plus.
See? I know this. It's magic portaaaaal.
- [Modern announcer:] Welcome to the arena outside of space and time,
where we have The Wonder Boy, The Matador:
2022 Luka Dončić.
- [Old-school announcer:] Versus 2008 Paul Pierce!
[club music]
- [Chuckling] I don't think so.
Give me a real challenge. I am HalleLuka.
I am Luka Magic!
- [Old-school announcer:] Have it your way, kid.
Your challenger will be multiple championship-winning,
Finals and league MVP, 1987...
Earvin "Magic" Johnson.
- It's an incredible honor to be with
you floating balls of light tonight.
- Woo, he smiled at me!
- No, he smiled at me!
- Hey, Ivan Drago, is this real?
- No, not Real. NBA.
- Oh, cocky, huh? You remind me of someone.
- [Old-school announcer:] Oh, Magic with the razzle-dazzle.
- [Modern announcer:] Magic misses a three,
showing he'd have no place in today's game.
- [Old-school announcer:] Luka's mesmerizing.
Like watching a tuna can do ballet.
- Ladies and gentleman: Showtime!
-Oh!
-Sorry, Magic Man, not my tempo.
- A white boy who can play? I think I know you.
Back to back, yeah!
- I don't back down, Earvin.
[record scratch]
I hit step-backs.
-Larry.
I'd know that slow, old-man game anywhere.
- [Old-school announcer:] I have not seen that look since the 1987 Lakers/Celtics Finals!
- Nice try with that terrible Euro disguise,
you dumb hick.
- Hick? I'm from Ljubljana. It's a big city.
-Magic fakes, Luka bites...Magic scores!
-Sorry, everyone. I was seeing green.
-[Crowd laughing] I don't get it, but he's so charming.
- Game point, Magic with the junior sky hook...
- [Old-school announcer:] Magic wins!
- Hey, let's do this again when you're grown.
-How do you like that schoolin', kid?
- Is it possible I do not have it all figured out
in my four NBA seasons?
Maybe there is hope for you children. Begin!
- [Gasps] Ow!
- OK, you gotta catch that.
- [Modern announcer:] Ok, so crypto is a type of-
- [Old-school announcer:] No. It'll never catch on.
- Didn't you say that about...
- A three point line?
No one's going to be
able to make that.
Look how far it is from the hoop!
I stand by that one.
Ruined the game.
- FTX. Don't miss out on the next big thing